agreeable people especially if they're
really agreeable are so agreeable that
they often don't even know what they
want because they're so accustomed to
living for other people
if you ask a disagreeable person what
what he wants say or she wants they'll
tell you right away they know it's like
this is what i want and this is how i'm
going to get it but agreeable people
they're so accustomed to living for
other people and to finding out what
other people want and to trying to make
them comfortable and so forth that it's
harder for them to find a sense of their
own desires as they move through life
and look there's situations where that's
advantageous but it's certainly not
advantageous if you're going to try to
forge yourself a career that just
doesn't work at all
and one of the things you have to be
careful of if you're agreeable
is not to be exploited because you'll
line up to be exploited say what you
think tell the truth about what you
think there's going to be things you
think that you think are nasty and harsh
and they probably are nasty and harsh
but they're also probably true and you
need to bring those up to the forefront
and deliver the message and it's not
straightforward at all because agreeable
people do not like conflict
not at all they smooth the water the
problem with that is it's not a very
good medium to long-term strategy right
because lots of times there are things
you have to talk about
because they're not going to go away and
the advantage to having a
well-socialized disagreeable person is
that they really don't let much get in
their way it's really useful to
investigate the viewpoints of people who
have opposing views to yours
because they'll tell you things not only
will they tell you things you don't know
they'll also tell you how to see the
world in ways that you don't see it and
they'll also have skills that you don't
have that you could develop
so for example if you're an introverted
person it's very useful to watch an
extroverted person because the
extroverted person has ways of being in
the social world that aren't natural to
you that you can use is to improve your
toolkit and if you're disagreeable one
of the best things to do with
disagreeable people especially if that's
alienating them from other people for
example because it can get the person to
do something for someone else once a day
just as a practice and learn how to do
it maybe you can wake the circuit up you
know if you think that it's lying
dormant in you which is probably right
you know i think we have a very wide
range of propensities within us some are
switched on
genetic propensity some are switched on
but i think that if you put yourself in
the right situation or walk yourself
through the right exercises you can
switch some of these other things on as
well but it takes work and and
dedication and discipline you know so if
you're hyper extroverted you should
probably learn to shut up at parties now
and then and listen just to see what's
going on to see if you can manage it you
know and if you're introverted well then
you should learn how to speak in public
and to and to learn how to go to parties
without hiding in the corner and saying
nothing to anyone
[Music]
you